hey Vsauce Michael here I've got a
question for you why did the chicken
cross the road
brilliant question let's find out why
historically the chicken crossed the
road to get to the other side has
anybody ever laughed at that joke why is
it become so famous and for that matter
who cares why would you want to
investigate why things are funny as EB
White said analyzing humor is like
dissecting a frog few people are
interested and the Frog dies but I want
to dive into the guts of this chicken
joke because today it is so famous it's
practically shorthand for comedy and
people frequently consider it either the
worst joke of all time or the oldest
joke but neither of those is true but
first things first
the chicken joke isn't technically even
a joke it's an anti joke it's a joke
about jokes
you see we expect a joke to surprise us
to flip things around or use wordplay
but to get to the other side is just
obvious it's mundane which by itself can
be pretty funny to make this more clear
let's take a look at anti-joke chicken
what's blue and smells like red paint
blue paint you see you expect a typical
jokey punchline but instead what you get
is hilariously serious anti-joke cat is
another good one knock knock who's there
lettuce that's impossible your mama is
so fat we are all extremely concerned
for her health anti jokes can also be
used for psychological experiments right
at home you may have heard of this one
already v no soap radio joke here's how
it works get a couple of your friends
together and tell them to all laugh when
you're done telling the joke no matter
what then go find a target who's not in
on it and tell them some version of a
joke like this two polar bears were
sitting in a bathtub the first one says
pass the soap the second one says no
soap radio at this point you and your
friends should
laughing uproariously meaning the target
has one of two choices either be afraid
of looking dumb and laugh along any way
or say they're confused at which point
you should tell them what you don't get
it and keep laughing you wait until the
target gives in to peer pressure and
succumbs to mob mentality and joins
despite the fact that no soap radio is
actually nonsense as for being the
oldest joke in the book why do the
chicken cross the road is far from it
it's only about a hundred and sixty some
odd years old it first appeared in print
in the Knickerbocker as a conundrum that
really isn't one an anti joke if you
want to look for the oldest joke ever to
appear in print we're going to have to
go back 4,000 years to read some ancient
Sumerian proverbs the joke is
essentially a cautionary tale to never
expect anything to be perfect it goes
like this something which has never
occurred since time immemorial a young
woman did not fart in her husband's
embrace so yeah
the earliest known joke is a joke about
a woman farting in the guy's lap so cool
all I'm sure of is that our proverbial
chicken did not have a ghayra phobia
that's the fear of crossing streets but
maybe the chicken should have I mean
crossing the road could be quite
dangerous for a little bird which leads
us to a quite darker interpretation of
the joke
maybe this chicken knew of the danger of
crossing the road maybe he knew what
could happen maybe he was sad or lonely
or knew what his fate was and so he
decided to take control and ended
himself and crossed the road
to get to the other side
[Music]
if you want to continue being morbid
check out Dethklok comm and answer a few
questions and the site will generate a
countdown of the number of seconds you
likely have left to live you can just
sit there and watch them tick away let's
get back to the joke perhaps a better
question then why did the chicken cross
the road
is why wouldn't chickens be crossing the
road I mean to be sure the earth is a
big place and less than 1% of it is even
paved but there are quite a few chickens
on earth to put this in perspective
there are about 500 million cats and as
far as we go there are 7 billion humans
but chickens there are 24 billion
chickens we're outnumbered
more than three to one but if we cooked
up every single chicken alive on earth
right now we could fill enough KFC
16-piece buckets to form a stack of them
going to the moon and back three times
unbelievable right I mean they all fit
so nicely here on Earth's surface
walking around with their
characteristically lean meat which
because fat contributes so much more
flavor to a piece of meat than the
muscle does may explain why chicken is
such a great generic meat flavor and why
so many other exotic meats we try later
tend to taste like chicken but let's get
back to the question in this video's
title why did the chicken cross the road
well to get to the other side sure but
there are many different motivations a
chicken could have for going to the
other side maybe it was looking for food
maybe it was being chased by a predator
what matters though is that we can never
know because there is no chicken it's
purely hypothetical as opposed to the
equally famous mary had a little lamb in
which the lamb and Mary were real people
Mary Sawyer was an actual student at the
Redstone School in Massachusetts and one
day her brother encouraged her to bring
her lamb to school
her fellow students were amused as was
visiting student John rule stone who
wrote mary had a little lamb' we have
actual documentation of those real
people and events but this chicken never
even really existed so asking why the
chicken crossed the road is just like
asking why did the original writer
decide that it should be a chicken
crossing a road which means that the
chicken crossed the road because some
comedian in the 19th century decided
that you would probably think about it
too much
making the mundane to get to the other
side answer quite surprising to explain
this let's look at a computational
neural explanation of humor in order to
effectively manage resources our brains
stay a few steps ahead of what we're
hearing estimating what kind of outcomes
are possible but when we discover that
were actually being told a joke and none
of our paths were the correct version of
what was being told all of that neural
network energy needs to dissipate and
according to some theorists that energy
moves into motor cortex causing
convulsions laughter unfortunately our
poor chicken friend doesn't elicit that
response from us anymore
because we've all heard the joke we know
what to expect when the joke begins but
we should be proud of our chicken friend
and the unknown author who thought them
up because even though the joke is so
famous it's no longer funny even at a
neurological level it still stands as a
testament to just how complicated and
clever our comedy can be keep laughing
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]